Yoel oh yay what was the first thought
of space that led you to opening up like
this in Calabasas and in Cody Wyoming
what was the seed of coming to a ranch I
was looking for a spot to start the easy
campus and we needed thousands of acres
so we went to the caldera house in
Jackson Hole and started looking for
property in Wyoming and I believe this
is the first property we looked at by
the time we were about to leave the
ranch I fell in love with it and I
bought it and now we're here how many
acres are we sitting on here this is
4,500 and we have another ranch that's
6,500 so what is your vision what all is
happening here now and how will it
unfold this will be one of the easy
campuses and the easy campus will have
the work that our architectural team has
been working on with James Turrell
and Claudio Silvestri to create spaces
that allow humans to maximize our
potential to take us out of the box
literally and figuratively we live in
boxes we leave the womb when we're born
and get put directly into the tomb we
can put directly into our first square
space which is the beginning of us going
from being multi-dimensional and
completely imaginative to placed onto a
grid those boxes are those grids the
first route starts off with the crib
then we go to schools where that's a box
then we go to higher learning a lot of
times that's a box and then we end up in
a job but we're working inside of a box
and then we do that to try to buy a crib
actually and then we you know
have children and then put our children
in a crib so instead of boxes the easy
way of life will look like what more
flow as some of the work for developing
and building those begun here already
yes it has where do we stand in the
process in the middle of it that's where
I always stand that's my favorite place
to stand in any process in the middle
it's always a process what is the
farming element that's underway at this
ranch or your other ranch we are going
to have hydroponic aquaponics passive
energy but I'm not the expert I work
with experts to create the best product
for Humanity and that was the original
idea behind Donda to have the best of
the best working together how do you see
Sunday service playing a role here we
definitely will have services here the
inventions and the developments and
innovations that I'm a part of always
become the new standard eventually will
people come to visit here or is it for
your family will people be able to
experience these shelters are developing
yes that would be some of the immediate
goals within our lifetime but ultimately
this would be the paradigm shift to
create platforms for free or thought
then the boxes that we're in now how
does travel go over there yeah yeah
have you tried these on right here
no I haven't either you can say
basketball on them